[Music]
now welcome back to CBS this morning
it's time to bring you some of the
stories that are the talk of the table
this morning is of courses where we each
pick a story we'd like to share with
each other and with all of you and gales
starting it up I'm going first this is
one of the most personal ones I've ever
done because this has never happened to
me before where someone I worked with
died unexpectedly so I'm still sort of
reeling from that our Hartford affiliate
it also understands what we mean at WSB
being flooded with condolence messages
from viewers after the sudden loss of
longtime news anchor Denise disenzo she
died unexpectedly at her Connecticut
home on Saturday night she was just 61
according to the station her family
believes that she died of a heart attack
now I work with Denise disenzo for many
years she was there we are she was there
for 33 years I was there for 18 her
colleagues are grief-stricken Denise I
can say that a variety of hairdos such
as funny to me now she won 11 Emmys in
her career Connecticut Governor Ned
Lamont described her as a news legend
which is true she is survived by her
husband and her daughter and this is the
thing guys it's one of those things
that's so shocking when you received the
news because Denise at 61 was in great
shape she was in great health I talked
to her husband and her daughter
yesterday who says she felt a little
indigestion in the morning she took some
tums went upstairs to go to bed they
just take a little nap he checked on her
four hours later and she was dead it was
that shocking right and we're all still
sort of reeling about this I talked to
many people over the weekend I saw Jon
LaPook at a dinner party last night and
he said one of the most important things
you can do is say to people I was
thinking about you something that we
never do because we so take it for
granted when I say that this woman was
kind and smart and talented I can't
emphasize that enough and I'm still well
when I got the news in California I was
visiting my favorites and he called me
yesterday to say how are you doing he
said I'm still bummed about it because
he remembers there's a little boy so
it's very upsetting when you get this
kind of news and just another reminder
to us about how we live our lives and
how important your health is she really
was one of a kind in the best of way and
that our time here is precious
exactly we spent 33 years at the station
and still seemed so young and you know
when you're at a local news anchor you
are a big deal yeah you are you've been
there for a long time you
beloved admired and respected I remember
when her daughter Catherine was born I
was talking to Catherine yesterday her
husband Wayne I just I'm still I can't
get over it I know it's all part of life
but it's still very stunning to me today
so I'm thinking about Denis and
Catherine and Wayne today where's my
friends at Channel three